in our district the poorest students are
left to the worst schools which is in
every district I know that's not new but
our district particularly is carving out
the high achieving niche and so they
have created elitist pockets that school
students from underperforming schools
are not really able to have access to
yeah 80th percentile or above you can't
have any discipline infractions you have
to have a certain test score and so what
they did is they pulled out to keep them
happy all of those students leaving the
other schools to sort of flounder we're
about 80 to 81 percent minority
population and most of which is
african-american and we have I think
according to our free and reduced lunch
counts where it's 68 percent free or
reduced lunch which is a really low
income level our culture here and our
expectations here are completely
different from what they encounter at a
lot of public schools the expectations
we have for morality for Ethics for
behavior are really new for a lot of
students our curriculum certainly makes
us unique
and I think that our expectations are
high expectations make us unique and
that's that's certainly something that
I've seen in dealing with past
performance versus current performance
is the change in expectations the change
in in standards and we took part in the
Barney foundations principal training
and faculty training
at Hillsdale and they absolutely loved
it
love meeting the other people involved
out of Dallas and out of New Mexico and
obviously dr. mournful Kilgore and then
this summer of Hillsdale training was
July 14 before I even had my feet wet
here I was back up in Hillsdale and that
was exciting because of the guidance so
it was all about how to what a classical
school should look like
and what procedures and policies should
be in place what you're going to run
into things like that so that was really
educational for me
and then Barney also sponsored a
two-week extra two weeks of faculty
training here in Savannah for all of our
faculty training them on on teaching
rigs Singapore math and the core
knowledge curriculum on top of just the
general again more of that school
cultural training what it should look
like how to deal with situation we had
all met for the first time as a faculty
like a week before we came in and we had
you know our our two-week intense
training we came in we had this big
binder of things from Hillsdale and we
had dr. Moore here and just sitting and
hearing about classical education
because none of us are from a classical
education background we had all done our
research and we were a little familiar
with it but to hear him talk to us about
what a typical classroom should look
like and the kinds of things they
expected the students to learn that was
very insightful because it kind of gave
us a push into oh these are the things
we've got to get on top of before the
children get here the second week of
school I gave a quiz and it was it was
on the continents in the oceans and
almost all 50 of my sixth-grade students
failed now on the quiz that they had
today
I had three FS
out of all those students letting them
have a wheel story to read and tear
apart and talk about is incredibly
rewarding I had one parent email me and
she said my son
has never read before on his own and he
just made me buy the 1905 Bulfinch
mythology and so now he has this like
entire collection of the Bulfinch myths
and he's been reading them to himself
and talking about the myths with his
parents and he was not a reader before
and so that was really cool to see like
oh when you expose kids to stories that
are actually exciting they really get a
chance to enjoy reading for the reasons
they're supposed to kids love it and
they actually love it K through six its
most most easily evident and seen in the
lower grades and hopefully you'll see
writing samples from day one to now and
you can't even tell us the same Tom's
handwriting it's fantastic and they're
learning how to spell things and you'll
you'll see children all of a sudden the
whole world becomes as puzzle all these
words everywhere you're learning you
know these combinations of letters and
all of a sudden you can start to piece
these words together and sound them out
and all of a sudden oh that's what
Virtue's looks like it's just and they
just light up
I think it's the best curriculum would
be the simple way to put it I think that
it's it's what best prepares students to
be thinkers and innovators instead of I
hate to say it this way but regurgitate
errs you know to to be able to to think
and to apply that knowledge and to learn
things that matter things that matter
beyond just success in a career things
that matter in life because this school
has really reached out to students who
have have been in underperforming
schools I see it as vision really for
the for the family affecting the
families as they go home and tell their
parents what they're learning they're
beginning to understand that that
there's so much more out there in terms
of knowledge the other piece of it for
me and and and it's really affected the
way that I teach my fifth graders now is
the idea of this responsibility we have
to uphold this great Republic we live in
and what a good citizen looks like the
biggest lie but everyone tell says is
that if you're poor or if you don't have
XYZ or if you come from here they're
this neighborhood of that that you can't
learn that you don't have the ability to
do it and that's just blatantly false
and we're sit we're here
you